help me understand
on the album you say um baron davis and
ronnie richard blood cousin yeah
real talk so your blood cousins roddy
and baron real talk
i said i didn't know i didn't even know
the roddy and baron were related like
that they probably
don't even know they probably didn't
even know you for what i'm saying
like it it it it just it just it just it
took a [ __ ] a little bit later to to
know that part you feel what i'm saying
especially roddy because my bro hit me
was like
he was like you know roddy that's our
cousin right
that's a little you know what i'm saying
there's a little government now he like
you know that's
i'm like yeah [ __ ] roddy is
my my my g-pops my jeep no my uncle is
his g-pops
oh that's how i go so you guys are like
for real related
that's crazy you guys have my dad that's
my dad brother my dad
brother my dad brother is my uncle
that's that's that naked granddad were
you um like like is that something you
found out recently or was that
man yeah i just found that out recently
bro
like you probably been around him and
[ __ ] he's not even knew it
his g-pops is my favorite uncle oh wow
okay
like that's that's what's crazy about it
damn
so you were like you guys i because i'm
assuming you're around like with the
racks in the middle
uh well you were always in the video
that's what i'm saying
obviously you know hit always tells us
that story about
how how legendary that session was you
know um
but yeah but you didn't even know that
was your cousin at the time that [ __ ]
crazy
that part i didn't know i found that out
later on in the game though that's crazy
that's crazy how this [ __ ] beat bro yeah
super crazy what about
obviously baron davis legendary la
figure one of the most slept on point
guards in nba history yeah man he's
super tapped in as well
yeah you know shout out to b diddy uh
you you guys have a strong relationship
or sure hell yeah yeah i pull up on him
faithfully
you know what i'm saying we have talks
you know what i'm saying we catch up
we reminisce how was it nice that when
he was on the clippers was that nice to
have like
man that's why that's why i'm a hell of
a clipper fan
right now you know what i'm saying not
really am i from l.a but like
you know what i'm saying my cousin brian
played for the club he was balling out
when he was on the clippers
for real yeah i had a [ __ ] play for the
clippers the warriors
hornets horny knicks for a little bit
next for a little bit yeah i'm saying
you know the warriors was the wave
though when he when they had that uh
that season uh where they where they
upset the one seed i think it was
they beat the mavericks in round one
yeah it was like matt barnes barry davis
michael peterson actually was legendary
yeah that's crazy